[Music]
which is how would you go about
converting a muslim
all people are converted the same way in
the sense that it is the spirit of god
there isn't a conversion style for a
muslim one for baptist one for atheists
it is the truth the convicting truth
apply to the person's heart by the
spirit of god that's how all people are
converted now you may adopt your
approach you understand your approach
but the truth of god everyone said the
truth affects all nationalities and by
extension all religions the same way the
truth spoken and the truth lived the
combination of truth spoken and truth
lived on the right time because jesus
said in john 16 12 i have yet many
things to say unto you but you cannot
bear them now it's not enough to speak
the truth we must speak at the right
time and so the conversion of a muslim
or hindu or whomever requires the spirit
of god working on that person through
the simple word of truth
spoken at the right time and the spirit
will lead you to the right time but all
people are converted by the spirit of
god
applying the word to the person's heart
and life
so you ask god what's the right time
and let god open the way for you and
he'll do that because he's not willing
that any should perish those who do
bible work must always keep this verse
in their mind second period three verse
nine the lord is not willing that any
should perish they should also keep in
mind first timothy chapter two verse
four who will have all men to be saved
and to come to the knowledge of the
truth so if your bible's uh worker
remember this it is god's will that
people come to the knowledge of the
truth keep this in mind as you do your
work very very noble work as a bible
worker or preacher or teacher whatever
your line of work may be
amen amen we must we must pray that god
give us a burden for souls
you see that's the problem we don't have
a burden for souls we just don't we
don't
we don't have a burden for souls we must
ask
because the carnal nature will never
manufacture a burden for souls we must
ask
god put upon me a love for souls
and he'll do that
amen amen but the love is not
accompanied by a knowledge of god's word
so you do not mislead the soul
that too
amen interestingly enough elder skeet um
one of the questions that was asked last
week um tied into the one that was just
asked which is there are many um muslims
and other denominations who say jesus
gave them a dream
they how come they're always going to
the sunday keeping church this is from
atma why can't god just show them his
sabbath
god shows people things at different
times
again i go back to john 16 12. i have
yet many things to say until you cannot
bear them now god knows the right time
to show people the sabbath truth or some
other truth you present truth the wrong
time you risk having it rejected and so
god knows when to present what and so if
a person is truly touched by the spirit
of god god will reveal truth at the
right time to that person so don't worry
about they went to sunday church
let the person continue to remain open
to the revelations of god's spirit and
god will lead the person in his or her
good time all people not converted the
same way under the same circumstances
amen but if the person is genuinely
seeking truth he or she will find it
because john 7 17 says if any man will
do his will he shall know the doctrine
so a willingness to obey truth is
essential to understand the truth
you